[Applaudissements]
oui nous fait un grand grand honneur
d'être dans touche pas à mon poste mais
pour le moment on accueille celui qui
sera avec nous tous les jours pour son
poste de surveillance camille combal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant au bal des cours camille combal
c'est un jour un jd un jour à givet
quant à une mère qui tricotent mais
c'est pas plaisir on est très très
content de recevoir camille alors qu'à
1000 postes de surveillance vous avez
surveiller quoi mais juste avant je
crois que vous avez des petites choses à
nous montrer un des petites choses à
vous montrer oui avant le poste de
surveillance d'abord comme chaque jour
découvrir un petit peu qui on a vu à la
télévision est aujourd'hui sur la
télévision française nous avons vu sur
bfmtv regarder des seniors nouvelle
coupe d'été qui lui va à ravir
nelson monfort jour on veut dans les
feux de l'amour en guest star johnny
hallyday
chez vous c'est lui
et sur le plateau j'ai très envie de
revoir johnny hallyday